genau eine woche nach seiner wahl hat
kanzler scholz im bundestag sein
programm vorstellt es gebe viel zu tun
und tatsächlich warten auf diese
regierung enorme aufgaben die bekämpfung
der pandemie die eindämmung des
klimawandels und dazu eine sorgenvolle
außenpolitische entwicklung nur wenige
stunden nach der regierungserklärung hat
die neue außenministerin zwei russische
diplomaten ausweisen lassen eskalation
nicht ausgeschlossen die neue koalition
muss ihren bürgern eine menge erklären
scholz antrittsrede was will der neue
kanzler unser thema heute in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
das moderne deutschland unser
deutschland ist ein starkes land wir
alle gemeinsam haben nicht den
geringsten grund uns vor der zukunft zu
fürchten
ganz im gegenteil er herzlich willkommen
aus berlin ein zuversichtlicher kanzler
zündet seine zuversicht auch darüber
sprechen wir mit diesen gästen ursula
weidenfeld ist bei uns freie
wirtschaftsjournalistin kolumnistin und
autorin ihr letztes buch ist eine
biografie über angela merkel will kommen
anja maier herzlich willkommen berichtet
über das politische geschehen für die
korrespondenten unter anderem für die
zeit und den weser kurier und ich
begrüße jan fleischhauer kommunist vom
focus und war früher im spiegel tätig
und herzlich willkommen heribert prantl
autor der süddeutschen zeitung und mit
ihnen herr prantl würde ich auch gerne
beginnen herr prantl der kanzler hat
gesagt wir haben keinen grund uns vor
der zukunft zu fürchten konnte scholz
heute ja den bürgern die furcht nehmen
ihrer meinung nach in seiner
regierungserklärung
auch er wäre schön gewesen wenn es so
gewesen wäre sie haben gerade gezündet
gesagt gezündet hat er gar nichts das
war eine sehr uninspiriert strecken weil
sie auch unkonzentriert die rede scholz
hat sich einige male verlesen bei der
von a bis z völlig abgelesenen rede der
koalitionsvertrag ist besser als die
rede des kanzlers ist war da war keine
wie der oppositionsführer
brinkhaus rückte da war keine
begeisterung da war nichts zu spüren
es waren ja ein paar sätze drin die
waren ganz ordentlich aber wenn es wenn
der neue kanzler von respekt redet wenn
er von fortschritt redet dann könnte er
sich ja mal kurz von geschriebenen
manuskripte lösen könnte erzählen was er
unter respekt verstehen was er und der
fortschritt versteht es fehlten die
sätze an denen man sich festhalten kann
an denen man die glaubwürdigkeit von
olaf scholz messen könnte ich denke
niemand der schweiz kennt hat erwartet
dass da jemand redet wie napoleon vor
den pyramiden oder wie ein sitzender ist
kein großer redner und das werde auch
nicht mehr werden aber es fehlte einfach
ein bisschen das gepackt sein dass
angerührt sein und ja es war eine
vertane chance ein bisschen mehr an
emotionen ein bisschen mehr
anfassen da zuhörerinnen und zuhörer
hätte schon sein müssen es war keine
gute regierungserklärung aber es ist nun
mal so und das wissen wir aus der
geschichte der republik eine gute oder
schlechte regierungserklärung ist noch
kein indiz für eine gute oder schlechte
amtszeit kam es schon glänzen die
regierungserklärung und gehabt die dann
wohl nichts darauf folgte insofern muss
man den heutigen tag nicht zu ernst
nehmen ok alba vertane chance und nicht
begeistern frau meier wie haben sie es
eher wie haben sie das wäre diese
regierungserklärung gesehen 86 minuten
dauerte sie glauben ja 86 minuten also
ich gebe natürlich dem kollegen prato
recht dass das jetzt keinen kein ausbund
das war kein feuerwerk den wir dabei
gewohnt haben aber ich würde es auch
gerne mal ein bisschen messen an der
vorgängerin von ihm die sich ständig in
irgendwelchen wird gestritten verzettelt
hat und der mann kaum folgen konnte was
sie eigentlich sagen will und das hat
zum beispiel oder scholz heute erledigt
mal ist man diesen job er spricht erst
mal einen klaren verständlichen sätzen
das ist ja schon mal ein fortschritt bis
hin
zum müntefering fehlt schon ein bisschen
was aber es war erstmal nachvollziehbar
was er eigentlich sagen möchte und aber
tatsächlich es war auch so eine
pflichtveranstaltung war er hat ja quasi
eigentlich den den koalitionsvertrag
referiert also ich dachte dann kommt
noch was aber es war dann doch punkt für
punkt für punkt ja also quasi die leute
darauf macht euch gefasst aber selbst
muss man sagen das war die erste
regierungserklärung und den vier jahren
werden wir das daran messen was davon
geblieben ist aber es war ja nicht seine
erste rede im bundestag also mehr weil
berlin großer redner also das was ich
finde es möchte ich noch kurz
einschränkt er gibt und man spürt er
arbeitet an sich sagen wir es mal so
also er wird schon besser das findet
empfinde ich so also air transat vertane
chancen sie sagen er wird schon besser
frau weidenfeld wie gut fanden
heute zur rhetorik ist ja alles gesagt
finde jetzt also für mich war total
überraschend dass das was wir an der
kanzlerin angela merkel immer vermisst
haben dass sie sagt warum sie etwas tut
dass sie dafür wirbt dass man gemeinsam
etwas tun wir es war kam unfassbar oft
in dieser regierungserklärung dass wir
und wir gemeinsam und wir sind nicht
gespalten das kam ganz oft vorn ich habe
immer gedacht und jetzt kommt aber
gleich auch was will was wollen wir mit
dem wir also was wie wie soll diese
transformation zu einer klimaneutralen
gesellschaft wie soll das funktionieren
und stattdessen kamen dann eben immer
nur es wird sich ganz viel ändern aber
ihr müsst euch nicht ändern also es kam
im grunde dass merkel haft nicht nur in
der rhetorik sondern eben auch im
inhaltlichen und da hat die koalition
eigentlich was anderes versprochen nicht
über dem über den koalitionsvertrag
stehen mehr fortschritt wagen und das
hat er ja auch in seiner rede zitiert in
seiner regierungserklärung und trotzdem
hat er da nicht geliefert und das fand
ich die größte lehrstelle das haben dass
das jetzt keine das heißt jetzt
langweilig war das hat glaube ich
niemand anders erwartet herr
fleischhauer haben sie sich auch
gelangweilt heute bei der
regierungserklärung
und ich habe sehr schnell durchlauf
gesehen das hilft gegen die langeweile
ich vereist mal eine sache lustig der
kanzler bezeichnet sich selbst als
intersexueller feminist und versuchte zu
gendern und wie er das macht finde ich
vorbildlich als er sagt einfach bürger
lieber bürgern bürger liebe liebe
unternehmer und unternehmer das feld
nicht so auf weil der hanseat ist also
eher verschluckt einfach das rennen
auch nach form das problem zu lösen
auf einer ernsteren note mir hat eine
sache gefehlt
also gerade im vorderen teil wo es um
die pandemie geht und uns ja jetzt ein
stimmt wieder auf einen schweren winter
hätte ich von dem kanzler erwartet wie
es zukünftig eigentlich mit dem gehalten
dem gebrochenen wort halten will also
wir haben ja nun alle möglichen
versprechungen in den letzten zwei
jahren auch von spitzenpolitikern bis
zur bundeskanzlerin
und auch hochrangigen spd vertretern
gehört also keine strengen maßnahmen
keinen lockdown wenlock da nur drei
wochen jetzt wieder auf keinen fall
einen lock down keine impfpflicht so
und er sagt selber also es werde keine
roten linien geben die regierung robbt
sich langsam an die impfpflicht dran ich
glaube es wirklich ist wäre an der zeit
dass mal der bundeskanzler erklärt in
künftig von sein versprechen zu halten
ist denn also wenn das nochmal jetzt
passiert eben ja impfpflicht haben wir
ausgeschlossen jetzt kommt zahlt und
dann sag mal steht die nächste
finanzkrise vor der haustür und er
stellt sich wie damals angela merkel wir
erinnern und sagt also lieber bürger
eure konnten sind sicher ob man hat
diese latte an versprochen und
versprechen im hinterkopf ich weiß nicht
ob die leute eben noch trauen werden
aber er hat doch klar gesagt es gibt
keine roten linie erklärte dass damit
nicht verbrannt wie haben sie das
empfunden
also ich finde ich unmöglich für
bundeskanzler das heißt es gibt keine
roten linien
ich kann nicht alles machen die roten
linien sieht das grundgesetz
und auch dieses grundgesetz hat dieser
kanzler vor ein paar tagen auch seinen
amtseid geschworen
der satz
bezieht sich wohl auf das
bundesverfassungsgericht dass der
politik einen weiten spielraum
eingeräumt hat aber diese weise dieser
weite spielraum ist ja keine unendlicher
spielraum hier gibt es klare linien und
auch ein kanzler kann nicht sagen ich
fühle mich durch nichts gebunden er ist
durch das grundgesetz gebunden und das
muss auch in gottes namen akzeptieren
auch wenn er ohne den lieben gott
schwört aber haben sie das verstehen sie
das so dass er dass der kanzler das
grundgesetz nicht ernst nimmt
nun ja ich musste ihnen nehmen was er
sagt wenn er sagt es gibt keine roten
linien dann gibt es keine grenzen für
die maßnahmen gegen korona da gibt dafür
grenzen selbst das
bundesverfassungsgericht
zieht ganz ganz ganz vorsichtig grenzen
ich denke da muss er sich auch wenn er
da den ganz entschlossen
menschen spielen will der ganz
entschlossen und politiker wird er jetzt
in den ersten kommentaren schon gelobt
dass er wenigstens sind den ersten 20
minuten in denen der über corona geredet
hat so etwas wie kleine branche momente
an entschlossenheit erkennen lässt aber
wenn ich diese entschlossenheit erkennen
lasse dann muss ich meine worte wägen
und die worte es gibt keine roten linien
da sehe ich dieses wegen der worte nicht
dass sie das so sehen
dieses der roten linien das hat er ja
bereits vor seiner vereidigung also es
ist jetzt nicht so dass das hätte ja
schon seit anderthalb zwei wochen im
mund und ich habe auch erst so ein
bisschen gestützt aber ich glaube ist
soll er umreißen dass er bereit ist zu
handeln also dass es gibt ja eine
überwiegende mehrheit im land von
menschen die irgendwie sagen so jetzt
genug diskutiert jetzt muss diese
regierung auch mal also er beansprucht
mit diesem mit diesem bild eigentlich
das neue so habe ich es verstanden nicht
dass er sozusagen das
bundesverfassungsgericht muss mitspielen
das dass es schon stimmt wenn
der kanzler geht an die grenzen
und testet ja auch die grenzen des
grundgesetzes das tut er ja nicht nur
bei der pandemie das tut die
bundesregierung ja auch wenn es um die
kreditaufnahme gibt und geht und da hat
ja schon die cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
angekündigt dass sie eine
normenkontrollklage beim
verfassungsgericht machen werden ich
glaube aber dass auf der anderen seite
jedoch relativ oder das ist sonnenklar
dass die bundesregierung dass der
kanzler das grundgesetz respektiert das
ist völlig klar ich glaube das schon
aber auch klar ist dass die grenzen der
verfassungsmäßigkeit mit dieser
regierung öfter getestet werden als
möglicherweise mit einer anderen
regierung aber und und dass diese
regierung da auch bereit ist ins risiko
zu gehen das zeigt sie aber dass die
regierung das grundgesetzlich
respektieren würde das kann man glaube
ich keiner möchte ist bei der bisherigen
deutschen klon
unterstellen dass meine der brandrauch
glaube ich nicht nein ist unterstelle
ich ihm auch nicht ob er sei ganz
einfach wenn es um solche existenziellen
fragen geht seine worte ein bisschen
regen und ein bisschen zügeln und der
satz es gibt keine roten linien besagt
letztendlich wir glauben wir können
ungeheuer viel machen und das ist nicht
das wort das ich mir bei aller
entschlossenheit der pandemie bekämpfung
von einem kanzler in der situation
erwartet
die regierung die muss jetzt ins handeln
kommen wir haben heute also ich habe es
ja eingangs gesagt wo es nach dieser
regierungserklärung
gab es jetzt eine zuspitzung im deutsch
russischen verhältnis weil die neue
außenministerin jetzt zwei diplomaten
der russischen botschaft zu
unerwünschten personen erklärt hat
nachdem es ein urteil gab gegen den
sogenannten tiergarten mord das sei eben
mord im staatlichen auftrag hat das
gericht geurteilt
wie bewerten sie denn diesen schritt
naja das ist jetzt erstmal so dass
annalena baerbock jetzt sofort ins ins
handel kommen muss also dass sie ist
eines der wichtigen gesichter der neuen
bundesregierung und kommt jetzt in die
situation diese entscheidung zu treffen
das ist glaube ich und unstrittig dass
das natürlich in absprache mit dem
kanzleramt gesprochen wurde die
situation mit russland ist ja ohnehin
sehr angespannt und die reaktion der
russischen botschaft ist auch ziemlich
hart ja also unterstellt ja der
botschafter unterstellt quasi dass das
politische justiz ist dass dieses urteil
bestellt ist das glaube ich nicht ich
denke das könnte vielleicht in seinem
land so sein aber trotzdem
ist das natürlich es gibt sofort also
mit einem der wichtigsten
internationalen partner einen richtig
harten krems jetzt da hat einer meiner
situation die eben extrem angespannt ist
mit mit russland herr fleischer wie
sehen sie das ist das die erste große
bewährungsprobe in der außenpolitik für
diese neue regierung und wie empfinden
sie da die reaktion der außenministerin
also der konflikt mit russland könnte
der erste große
konflikt sein den diese neue
bundesregierung durchzustehen hat das
stimmt schon also diese tiergarten
geschichte ja also erstens war nicht
überraschend dass also man hat im kgb
willst du den nachfolgeorganisation mehr
zugetraut als ich besonders hart
erwischen zu lassen dann haben sie sich
erwischen lassen es gab das urteil so
wie man es erwartet hat
dann werden halt zwei diplomaten
ausgewiesen ist jetzt auch nicht ganz
neu ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt cent
putin so wahnsinnig beeindruckt also
wichtiger ist die frage wenn auf der
anderen seite der ukrainischen grenze
100 tausend russische soldaten
zusammengezogen werden ob wir den
ukrainern die waffen liefern die sie
brauchen
so und da ist die bundesregierung aber
nicht sehr gespalten in der frage also
das heißt immer defensivwaffen ja aber
wenn nicht richtig gelesen habe die
frage zb von von präzisions gewähren
die ist die lieferung ist im
anbietermarkt von deutschland
gescheitert so und insofern also die
diese diese nummer wir weisen zwei
diplomaten aus beeindruckt mir nicht so
wahnsinnig glaube auch nicht das ist
alles ein bisschen theaterdonner
ich glaube es ist schon ein bisschen
mehr als das ist ja nicht ein es ist ja
nicht ein einzelner vorfall sondern
sozusagen ein vorfall in einer kette von
vorfällen von ereignissen die sich
gegenseitig entweder auf schaukeln oder
die sich gegenseitig bedingen und das
ist schon wichtig wieder jeder einzelne
schritt aussieht es geht eben natürlich
auch um die erdgaspipeline nord stream
es geht um die ukraine es geht schon um
sehr sehr viel dabei und von daher würde
ich das nicht so banalisieren und auch
nicht
unterschätzen
die frage wie die aussenministerin da
agiert dass sie zumindest den eindruck
erweckt konsequent sein zu wollen und
dass sie das auch durchziehen will das
ist jedenfalls schon mal ein signal und
es zeigt eben um soll wahrscheinlich
auch zeigen dass die deutsche
außenpolitik durch den wechsel nicht
unsicher geworden ist und nicht
verhandelbar geworden ist das ist ich
kann das nicht beurteilen ob das signal
vernünftig ist und ob es am ende dann
auch zu einer vernünftigen außenpolitik
führt aber dass es so ganz lächerlich
ist das glaube ich nicht herr prantl es
gibt ja den konflikt ich habe schwere
ich habe damit den punkt doch noch mal
also ich hab mir nicht gesagt ich das zu
banal halte also dass
killer im tiergarten unterwegs sind ja
die reaktion darauf halte ich für
theater dollar aber er ist
dafür entscheidend halte nämlich die
nehme ich die frage der ukraine so und
wenn wir sehen in der bundesregierung
und insofern das mag jetzt sehr tapfer
von frau bär box sein für diplomaten
auszuweisen aber wenn gleichzeitig mütze
nicht erst vor kurzem mutter
fraktionschefin alle der mächtigsten
männer in der spd war von einer
gegenseitigen aufschaukeln der spirale
spricht so als ob die ukraine
gleichzeitig die russen bedrohen würden
das heißt genau diese art von von von
von merkwürdigem definierung von
verantwortung kann mich an mein tag das
so ist in einem teil der bundesregierung
einzug hält ich glaube das ist viel
wichtiger und die frage ist ja wie sehr
die die bundesregierung da gemeinsam
agiert stichwort gazprom herr prantl ist
ja die frage da gibt es ja ganz klar
unterschiedliche ansätze zwischen grünen
und spd also wie sehr welche war wie
denken sie wie diese neue regierung in
der außenpolitik wirklich dann gemeinsam
agieren kann
ich weiß es nicht weil sie müssen sich
zusammenraufen und dieses zusammenraufen
hat nicht monate zeit ich denke die
reaktion auf das urteil zum tiergarten
mord ist eine klare reaktion ist eine
notwendige
reaktion es ist auch mehr als
theaterdonner es gehörte zu den
diplomatischen
regen auf solche
taten auf verbrechen in bestimmter weise
zu reagieren
es wäre keine gute reaktion jetzt in die
ukraine waffen zu liefern ich meine
diese art und weise und dann tatsächlich
eskalierend einzugreifen ist nicht das
probate mittel ganz gleich wie in berlin
an der regierung ist man muss schauen
wie kann ich ohne einen krieg zu
befördern die sache deeskalieren und die
drohungen die ja schon massiver art sind
aus washington und die sich berlin
angehängt hat sind wir schon sehr
deutlicher natur und ich würde jetzt mal
abwarten wie reagiert putin der westen
und auch die bundesrepublik die
bundesregierung muss klar machen dass
sie eine
militärische reaktion einen krieg
keinesfalls so hingehen lässt die
drohungen müssen glaubhaft und massiv
sein wenn wir es ist ein thema eines von
vielen themen daraus heute wir nehmen
wir haben jetzt länger darüber
gesprochen weil es halt eben heute noch
mal diesen aktuellen anlass gab aber
wenn man die ganze liste sieht von
herausforderungen und themen frau
weidenfeld dann kann einem ja fast
schwindelig werden in so einer zeit halt
eben zuerst natürlich diese corona
pandemie und wo der kanzler aber auch
sagt ich will will der kanzler natürlich
aller seien auch der ungeimpften er sagt
auf der andere es gibt keine spaltung
der gesellschaft also schafft er es mit
seiner anspannung heute schafft er es
die leute mitzunehmen in diesen in
diesen schwierigen zeiten ich bin mir
nicht sicher ich glaube dass diese
beschwörungsformel es gibt keine
spaltung der gesellschaft
ich finde die sehr attraktiv ich glaube
nicht dass sie stimmt und ich glaube
dass viele menschen den eindruck teilen
dass es eben nicht stimmt dass es
natürlich menschen gibt die der
auffassung sind gerade bei krone aber ja
auch schon in den fragen die wir vorher
diskutiert haben mit der vorherigen
bundesregierung
migration
das dass es menschen gibt die
den weg der
mehrheitsgesellschaft und ich teile
nicht teilen wollen und dass die
mehrheitsgesellschaft zunehmend
ungeduldig wird wenn sie sich mit diesen
minderheiten beschäftigt und ich glaube
auch nicht dass so eine art butterkuchen
formel es gibt keine spaltung der
gesellschaft
deshalb machen faxen packen das jetzt
mal alle gemeinsam an dass das
funktioniert das kann ich mir einfach
nicht gut vorstellen ich halte es auch
nicht für klug und ich glaube dass die
beiden also wenn ich noch sagen was ich
vermisst habe in dieser
regierungserklärung der ehemalige
finanzminister sagt kein wort wirklich
kein wort zu den staatsfinanzen
wie das finanziert werden soll wie man
am verfassungsgericht vorbild wie man
sich so ein bisschen rum um mogel zu
sagen wir konnten das mit der
schuldenbremse nicht schaffen dazu sagt
der ehemalige finanzminister der heutige
kanzler gar nichts das ist aber etwas
was menschen bewegt und was die viele
menschen in deutschland in zukunft auch
sehr sehr aufbringen will wird und
zweitens zu sagen wir werden ganz viel
verändern aber es verändert sich für
euch nix weil wir das alles irgendwie
wuppen auch das ist so nimmt formel
bei der jeder packen kann dass funkel
wird auch nicht funken ein beispiel weil
er hat ja gerade viele fahren gern mit
dem auto und das soll auch so bleiben
das ist der immobilienfonds sein dass du
dir ja das was dazu aber ich finde auch
nicht dass er das nur gemacht hat also
er hat ja auch wenn ich mich recht
erinnere ich habe jetzt nicht alles mit
geschrieben aber so er hat ja gesagt es
wird sich vieles ändern ja für jeden von
uns aber wer hat ja nicht gesagt euch
passiert gar nichts also wir nur wir
ändern was und
und den bürgerinnen und bürgern für die
bleibt alles klar danach seine satzung
war das sicher dass alles in sicherheit
sind also
nicht zu ändern und die diese
finanzpolitische geschichte das finde
ich auch dann gebe ich ihnen vollkommen
rechter blieb er völlig vage und sie
haben ja auch recht darauf bin ich gar
nicht gekommen der war ja eben noch
bundesfinanzminister
sich alles was wir uns wünschen werden
wir finanzieren können wichtig ist dass
wir wachsen in der quasi dass wir als
land als gesellschaft als wirtschaft
wachsen und dann können wir auch alles
noch finanziert das ist natürlich
wirklich sehr schwammig das stimmt ja
aber dass er gesagt hätte sozusagen euch
passiert gar nichts das habe ich so
nicht gehört naja also dieses denken
jedes wort ist fortschritt was er immer
bemüht und der veränderung herr
fleischhauer ist fortschritt heißt ja
doch aber auch gleichzeitig werden sich
so viel verändern muss dass man den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ja auch etwas
zumuten muss
warten was denken sie weiß jetzt
versuchen das geht und wie geht er damit
um ich weiß also ja also die
journalisten lieben das immer also
zuerst progressive bündnis und den
leuten zu sagen es wird jetzt wahnsinnig
veränderung über ich euch ja einbrechen
die wähler nicht und ehrlich gesagt die
stimmung nach zwei jahren pandemie mit
einem möglicherweise neuen doktor und
vor der tür ist jetzt so dass urlaub
einfach mal durchatmen wollen also jetzt
dadurch der bundeskanzler noch
hinstellen sagt und ob auf all die
beschwernisse die ihr hattet ja werden
wir euch mal richtig einheizen und ihr
werdet euch gleich mir sozusagen wieder
erkennen wie sich euer leben verändert
nee nee das so wenn ich das in seiner
klasse schuldig gewesen wer nicht selbst
leute lasst das er flächen weil sie ein
total recht aber ich glaube dass eine
neue bundesregierung die ihren
koalitionsvertrag überschreibt mit mehr
fortschritt wagen und die sagt wir
stehen vor einer gewaltigen
transformation was ja auch jeder weiß
dem dem wähler schon auch schulde zu
erklären wie das gehen soll und zwar
unabhängig davon wie gestresst die
bürger jetzt schon sind und unabhängig
davon ob sie sich noch mehr zumuten
wollen aber dass man erklärt ob du gibst
du was man will und dass man dafür auch
wird das halte ich eigentlich für
unverzichtbar ich hab mich immer
gewundert dass es bei angela merkel so
lange gut gegangen ist das sind es nicht
getan aber wer kann sich noch muss das
tun aber da gibt es noch gelegenheit
die taxierung erst schauen das ist jetzt
die erste regierungserklärung
in einer nun auch schwierigen zeit wo
natürlich das ganze programm das sich
die regierung vorgenommen hat
durcheinandergeraten ist ja klar aber zu
sagen nur noch zehn mal und beim zehnten
mal machen wir dann ernst das halte ich
auch nicht für richtig ja
ich weiß ich bin ich bis dahin schon
soll sich mal wirklich verweisen also
dass wir die alles machen ich habe mich
normal dass wir dich nochmal ich fand
auch interessant diese dieses geschichte
mit wir sind kein gespaltenes land ja
und jetzt sozusagen also eher dass wir
die stärkste passage wo er sozusagen
sich die extremisten vornimmt naja also
eine kleine radikale minderheit in
deutschland die neben fackel märsche
macht vor entweder dem haus von vor
schwierig oder dem haus der sächsischen
ministerin also die gegend es gilt es
sind ja derzeit gesondert die gehören
nicht mehr dazu und alle anderen aber
irgendwie sorgen wir müssen uns nun mal
die zahlen angucken also ich hab das
neue team ausrechnen lassen also wir
haben etwa 23 millionen ungeimpfte in
deutschland wenn wir die unter
18-jährigen daraus rechnen haben wir
zwölf millionen erwachsene die sich
nicht haben impfen lassen und von dem
mann aus umfrage war es die wehrt sich
an immer groß impfen lassen 12 millionen
das ist ziemlich genau die zahl die olaf
scholz und die spd bei der
bundestagswahl im september gewählt
haben das ist doch nicht eine kleine
minderheit das ist also ich würde mal
sagen das ist echt eine spaltung wenn
ein ende die gleiche anzahl von menschen
die die spd ins kanzleramt bugsiert
haben sagen nein wir lassen uns nicht
impfen und jetzt eine impfpflicht auf
uns zurollt ich bin echt mal gespannt
wie das ausgehen wird das spiel ja die
frage ist wie kann er die mitnehmen herr
sprankel wenn er sagt er ist ja auch der
kanzler der ungeimpften also wie kann
das funktionieren kann das aufgehen
es waren etwas eigenartige setzte wird
es formuliert hat einerseits sorgt er
ist der kanzler der ungeimpften
andererseits sagte er will aber die noch
überzeugen er sagt nicht wir sie
überzeugen will er sagt die ins kritiker
seine ganz ganz kleine minderheit diese
minderheit setzt er gleich mit denen die
gewaltbereit sind und so ist es nicht es
gibt mehr die distanziert sind die
sich impfen lassen wollen aber gegner
einer impfpflicht sind und die alle in
einen topf zu werfen sowie das gemacht
hat halte ich für falsch er hat es
gemacht deswegen weil er begründen
wollte warum er sagt es gibt keine
spaltung der gesellschaft es gibt da
unabhängig von corona eine spaltung der
gesellschaft eine sehr vielfältige
spaltung die
olaf scholz recht gut kennt deswegen hat
er jahre mindestlohn von 12 euro
eingeführt und viele soziale maßnahmen
in den koalitionsvertrag aufgenommen die
die spaltung die multiple spaltung der
gesellschaft lindern sollen kroner
vertieft diese spaltung die anti corona
maßnahmen in ihrer großen bandbreite
treffen die bevölkerungen sehr
verschiedener weise
die gastwirte die kulturschaffenden
sind vielmehr getroffen heißt beamte und
andere bevölkerungsgruppen da muss man
sehen hier gibt es unterschiedliche
auswirkungen dieser maßnahmen und auch
eine unterschiedliche sichtweise dieser
maßnahmen
also das kann man ja so nicht übergehen
also sie haben ja recht dass es so zu
sagen es gibt eine multiple spaltung es
gibt diese und jene es gab schon immer
welche und so das finde ich auch aber
nicht sagen dass alle
es gibt längst nicht sagen dass alle die
mas die die maßnahmen kritisieren
radikalisiert sind die der dem
radikalismus muss man wirklich massivst
entgegentreten den
verschwörungstheoretikern muss man
massiv entgegentreten aber nicht jeder
der die nasen namen kritisiert ist und
verschwörungstheoretiker und ein gros
video da muss man die kirche im dorf
lassen man muss diskutieren man das werk
nicht mehr
gesprochen
was wir ja sehr stark sehen ist eine
spaltung im bundestag das ganz klar ist
die afg steht auf der ganz anderen seite
in diesem thema als die aller anderen
fraktionen und es gab heute ja auch
bei der wahl der bundestagsausschüsse
beim innenausschuss und beim
gesundheitsausschuss ist jeweils der
kandidat der afg nicht gewählt worden
von den anderen fraktionen ist es
richtig frau weidenfeld weil das ist ja
auch ein punkt wo man zeigt wie geht man
mit opposition mit in einem thema wie
corona wo eigentlich alle an einem
strang ziehen müssen also ist es hilft
dass dabei ich habe mich total gewundert
dass im vorfeld die ampel koalition und
die cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
das in kauf genommen haben dass die afg
den innenausschuss wählt dass diese
eskalation jetzt in dieser woche oder
heute nachmittag stattgefunden hat das
war ja eigentlich total unnötig man
hätte der afg den ausschussvorsitz in
anderen ausschüssen überlassen können
aber den innenausschuss sozusagen
freizugeben zur wahl das war totaler
quatsch und ich kann auch verstehen dass
jede partei um jede fraktion ihre
eigenen gründe dafür hatte
andere ausschüsse zu wählen aber dass
man riskiert dass der innenausschuss an
eine partei geht die vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird das
halte ich für total verrückt und glaube
es ist einfach so passiert hatte man
keine strategie also entweder hat man
sich vorher nicht unterhalten oder man
hat die augen zugemacht eines von beiden
ist passiert und das daneben ihnen diese
also dann heute nachmittag eben
praktisch damit zu beenden dass man den
kandidaten durchfallen lässt das ist der
versuch dem vorher entstandenen schaden
zu heilen notbremse aber in der
notbremse die natürlich unheimlich für
alle beteiligten ist ja kommt zu spät
finde ich auch hätte man muss also da
hätte man vielleicht mal das ist auch
was ist sozusagen auch in der ganzen
kabinettsbesetzung uns oder gibts ja
auch schaubild da wird jemand
durchgestrichen reingenommen
rausgenommen da wird geredet und
ausgerechnet beim innenausschuss ja der
wird dann quasi so gegeben ja eben genau
diese dieser fraktion und das fand ich
auch sehr schwierig und so viel ich weiß
habe ich gehört liegt das vor allem auch
an den grünen ja und die den
europaausschuss fuhren aber weil die den
europaausschuss wollten für für anton
hofreiter und das finde ich schwierig
also das muss ich auch sagen das ist ein
ganz ungutes was heute sozusagen noch
mal also da kann jetzt sozusagen die auf
dem opfern an diesem punkt und das ist
einfach das sollte man eigentlich
vermeiden diese diese lage schwierige
lage
brandl und dann vielleicht recht aber
bei einem satz bei einem sonst ziehe ich
nicht mehr das ist eben gesagt worden
bei kroner müssen wir alle an einem
strang ziehen das müssen sie nicht ich
muss das infektionsschutzgesetz ich muss
die einzelnen maßnahmen im bundestag
debattieren ich will sie nicht haben
dass hier die afg als gesamt und global
kritikerin auftritt ich hatte mir von
einem bundestag ich erwarte mir von den
demokraten die fraktionen dass sich die
einzelnen maßnahmen wirklich
differenziert diskutiere es darf nicht
die devise ausgegeben werden alles was
irgendwie
die überschrift corona bekämpfung trägt
ist per se richtig und per se gut dass
an einem strang ziehen wenn die
maßnahmen dann beschlossen werden ja
aber sie müssen vorher diskutiert werden
und sie müssen intensiv diskutiert
werden und die bürgerinnen und bürger im
land müssen das gefühl haben der
bundestag ringt und da regen wirklich um
die einzelnen maßnahmen weil das um
existenzielle dinge geht und um die
existenz von 10.900 tausenden von
menschen ich wollte damit auch nicht
ausdrücken dass man nicht darüber
diskutieren soll aber ich denke also
dass das die bekämpfung als eine
gemeinsame aufgabe betrachtet wird das
denken würde ich sagen herr fleischer
wie würden sie sagen sie ja
panik also ich bin ja selten der meinung
von herrn prantl bekanntlich alle war
russland 12 liegen wir erkennen wir
auseinander an dem punkt hat er das
total recht also jetzt letztlich jeden
der sich nicht irgendwie lässt irgendwie
so und als spinner oder schlimmer noch
als nazi zu bezeichnen wie gesagt ich
weiß nicht ob das bad ist es sich um
eine größenordnung von 12 millionen
menschen handelt ob das wirklich klug
ist wer macht händel und jetzt die afd
als die afg ist für mich ein kasperle
truppe ja also eine partei die ernsthaft
den eilantrag beim
bundesverfassungsgericht
stellt weil sie sagt ja also wir haben
so viele ungeimpfte in unseren reihen
und wollen sich testen lassen und jetzt
können wir bei der abstimmung im
bundestag vorher nicht in berlin
übernachten weil der g2 g + regeln da
muss das bundesverfassungsgericht uns
helfen wie man das nicht mehr ernst zu
nehmen so also ich glaube wir dürfen
diese wie gesagt den protest und auch
die zweifel an der krone politik der
bundesregierung nicht in eins der zehn
mittel protest und dem irrsinn die die
ftd schreibt dann noch mal dann haben
wir den der afg neues großes thema
geschenkt hat und auch schaffen sollten
doch schon aufgenommen die afd die frage
ist wie geht man damit aber das ist ich
kenne also ich kenne reihe von leuten
also ich kenne reicht von leuten die aus
verschiedensten gründen sich nicht
impfen
diese stehen so weit weg von der afg
also normal also die zwölf millionen das
sind immerhin das sind bei den
wahlberechtigten 25 prozent so groß ist
ja
besser weshalb läuft ja bei den leuten
gerade weg aber sie haben können was
dafür tun
dass die afg immer größer wird indem er
jeden sozusagen
jeden zweifel
auch zum beispiel an lockdown maßnahmen
so runter reden ich meine wenn wenn
jemand wie nicht hat david precht ja bis
eben noch einen der beliebtesten und
populärsten fernseh philosophen in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
in filtern aufmacher niedergemacht wird
weil er zweifel an der korona politik
äußert und zwar mit den sätzen in der
fas er habe zweifel gesät an den
staatlichen institutionen und den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
gefährdet ist aber angesagt da bin ich
ja ganz bald erreicht hat david precht
dass du die aufgabe von philosophen und
journalisten dachte ich die staatlichen
institution in frage zu stellen
sie haben total recht aber ich glaube
aber nur also man kann doch nicht
übersehen dass die afd
profitiert von diesen typischen dagegen
themen also migration oder gegründet
worden ist sie ja in der in der euro
krise als es ihm um die frage ging
hilft helfen die staaten euro-staaten
griechenland oder lassen sie es bleiben
sie ist dann stark geworden wieder in
der in der in der migrations krise und
jetzt in der korona pandemie findet sie
wieder ihre rolle und das glaube ich
muss man doch irgendwie sehen und auch
erkennen können dass die fdp ihre
gespräche jetzt im protest findet bitte
schön herr prantl gespräche deswegen
weil wir in der af weil wir gerade in
der kroner politik gesehen haben dass
die kfd mit ihrer
pauschalen kritik mit ihrem zu hauen in
der bundestagswahl gar nichts gerissen
hat
man war doch ihr so dass man sagte die
haben ihre eigenen ziele nicht erreicht
das ergebnis daher fd deswegen ja noch
viel schlechter gewünscht hätte ja nicht
wirklich
gesehen
sondern auch mal weiter über den olaf
scholz und die ampelkoalition die frage
was sie was muss sie den bürgern
zunehmend zumuten ist gab heute eine
menge applaus zum beispiel als er noch
mal klar gesagt hat wir streichen den §
209 10 a da geht es um das gewerbe
heißes verbot führen von über
schwangerschaftsabbrüche gegen das
selbstbestimmungsrecht frau herrmann hat
das gefühl da sind ist eine menge was
was so anders ist und da gab es viel
applaus ja dass die betriebstemperatur
einer dich also das hat man auf der
einen seite sank sie natürlich
ablaufdaten an seite gegen sie richtig
hoch das sind eigentlich finde ich
vieles davon also vor allem zuwanderung
ja ist ja auch ein thema der fdp gewesen
die jetzt dieses punktesystem nach
kanadischem vorbild einführt das sind
streitpunkte gesellschaftliche
streitpunkte riesen themen die in der
der regierung in der regierungszeit von
angela merkel sozusagen hoch und runter
diskutiert wurden aber nie entschieden
am ende ging es immer also vielleicht
noch die ehe für alle 2017 war das
glaube ich das war so ein ausrutscher
quasi und jetzt zeigt diese neue
fortschrittlich wie sie sich nennt
bundesregierung koalition sagt halt
diese dinge die sind ganz einfach die
lösen wir jetzt
das
fleisch aber bitte da liegt natürlich
auch am meisten allerdings auch glaube
ich konfliktpotenzial also ist man das
werbeverbot streicht bei paragraf als
bei abtreibung § 209 10 a mit dagegen
die meisten leute mit bei der frage
gehen wie eine paragraf 218 ran da weiß
ich nicht ob es einen gesellschaftlichen
konsens gibt das in paragraph 218
streichen also diesmal die diskussion
erinnert gereinigt das war echt mühsam
gefundenen kompromiss so und wenn man
einen koalitionsvertrag schaue willie
williams interessante formulierung er
half ihr habt die koalitionsvertrag
nicht gelesen da steht drin
abtreibung sei ein gesundheitsrat dass
es künftig kostenlos jeder frau zur
verfügung gestellt wird und alle
feministinnen zwischen teresa bücker die
das gelesen haben haben geburten habe
gesagt dass der einstieg in das ende des
paragraphen 218 denn eine etwas was nach
wie vor bislang rechtswidrig ist
kostenlos über die gesund über die
krankenkasse finanziert das wird ja wohl
nicht gehen
wo ist das problem
was ist jetzt ihr problem damit ich
verstehe das nicht ganz ich glaube dass
diese also wenn das handy wenn die
regierung an diesem punkt ernst machen
will und sagt okay in zukunft ist
abtreibung also etwas was bislang wie
gesagt als rechtswidrig in deutschland
gilt nun nicht strafrechtlich verfolgt
wird von der krankenkasse zu übernehmen
das möglichst fit bislang nicht von der
krankenkasse übernommen aus genau diesem
grund und das machen wir jetzt dass das
ist nicht mehr kostenpflichtig also
glaube ich wird eine diskussion über den
§ 118 aufbringen ich sage ja noch gar
nicht will ich dazu denke ich sage nur
das ist jedenfalls da gehen wir dann ja
das war gerade gelehrt dass diese
regierung alles abräumen würde was denn
passiere bislang liegen geblieben ist
dann will ich mal sagen da geht sie
jedenfalls auf ein konfliktfeld
bei anderen dingen gibt es die gefahr
dass diese koalition mit diesen mit
dieser art die teile der gesellschaft
auch überfordert
ich sehe ich keine überforderung bei den
gesellschaftspolitischen dingen wir
haben die einwanderung mit einer
regelung die schon in der ersten großen
koalition angedacht worden ist dann
alles im bundesrat an in der gespaltenen
stimme von brandenburg gescheitert wir
könnten das schon seit 16 jahren haben
es ist
auch eine diskussion die früher von
herrn schäuble geführt worden ist also
noch innenminister war da ist wirklich
viel nachzuholen im
gesellschaftspolitischen bereich im
adoptionsrecht
im staatsbürgerschaftsrecht da liegen
die probleme wirklich schon lange da und
diese probleme werden mit den vorhaben
die im koalitionsvertrag genannt werden
abgeräumt das bei 218 und im
konfliktfeld auftritt wie es der kollege
fleischer befürchtet sich überhaupt
nicht es ist so dass die abtreibung
straflose damit auch straflos bleiben
die an seinen rechtlichen probleme
glaube ich spielen hier keine rolle und
wenn die krankenkassen hier herangezogen
werden wird es kein großes
gesellschaftliches konfliktfeld sein die
streiten streitigkeiten die zeit des
großen streit über die abtreibung die ja
zu etlichen urteilen beim
bundesverfassungsgericht führte zu einem
langen hin und her die ist vorbei ich
denke im gesellschaftspolitischen
bereich werden wir wenig konfliktfelder
haben da ist die
gesellschaftliche zustimmung sehr breit
da haben wir vielleicht den kleinen
anschluss an die branchen
regierungszeiten und die
großen aufbruch der zivilgesellschaft
den es damals gehabt
zum ausdruck der wirklich der wirklich
dekliniert ist sie nicht hätte mir
gewünscht dass heute
den begriff fortschritt tatsächlich dick
linie der hat dann gesagt es geht
technologischen fortschritt das gibt
sozialen fortschritt es gibt
gesellschaftspolitischen fortschritt
aber er hat es nicht mehr durch nägel
enthält die gewünschte wichtig gewesen
von aufbruchstimmung da gemerkt nähe und
ich glaube dass eben das was jetzt
beschrieben worden ist als so groß dass
konsensuale es fällt also dass
gesellschaftlicher wandel neben auch
dann nachvollzogen wird im gesetz das
hat glaube ich das ist ja so eine art
notarielle aufgabe und damit tut sich
natürlich nicht
die koalition viel viel leichter als
eine koalition in der eine konservative
partei vertreten ist die eben immer noch
mal zurückkommt und sich eben auch fragt
sind die werte die wir da jetzt aufgeben
sind die wirklich schon über ständig
oder lohnt es sich die zu verteidigen
gab war angela merkel sie haben die ehe
für alle erwähnt erstaunlich
unsentimental wenn es darum ging
irgendwie dinge über bord gehen zu
lassen die über die die zeit
hinweggegangen ist und diese regierung
kann es natürlich zu einem politischen
inhalt machen ganz anders als eine
regierung in der cdu cdu csu vertreten
sind weil sie eben diesen
gesellschaftlichen wandel praktisch in
ihrer identität
das gehört zu ihrer identität sie muss
sich nicht dagegen stellen die luft raus
an den aber es ist eben keine gestaltung
also ich glaube da muss man eben schon
noch mal sehr genau aufpassen dass man
einer neuen regierung eben auch
gestaltungsaufgaben abverlangt wie ab
rankel das gerade formuliert hat ich
glaube das ist nicht das ist nicht banal
also man kann nicht sagen dass das was
im gesellschaftlichen bereich was die
vorhaben dass es wirklich gestalterisch
ist das ist das nachvollziehen eines
wandels der stadt gefunden hat und den
man jetzt eben in gesetze liest die
anderen sachen müssen dann aber jetzt
folgen frau meier wie viel angst muss
die koalition vor der opposition haben
also vor der attacke die cdu herr
brinkhaus der fraktionschef war heute
der war der wachmacher
da hatte man sagen angst muss im moment
nicht haben also weil er bringt haus ja
auch angekündigt hat wir werden euch
kritisch aber kollegial begleiten fair
wir werden wir wollen haben vorfährt zu
bleiben wollen wir mal schauen ob das so
ist aber das macht er natürlich auch aus
zwei gründen das eine ist er möchte gern
fraktionschef bleiben er will ja auch
mal eine ganz große nummer drehen und
das andere ist sie wolle die union muss
aufpassen dass sie nicht quasi
inhaltlich im gleichschritt kommt mit
der afg sie muss sich stark abgrenzen
von dieser fraktion und das hat er heute
brammo ist muss ich sagen hingekriegt
hat er gut gemacht der fleischhauer
waren sie zufrieden mit herrn brinkhaus
er ist ja vielleicht aber auch nicht
zufrieden mit ihr mit der opposition
[Gelächter]
ich lobe den tag an dem diese ganze
truppe jetzt mal abtreten musste das
buch ich sagen also für mich waren die
letzten zwei jahren eine qual ich bin
jetzt mal gespannt also herr lauterbach
hat ja so eine inventur gemacht und sagt
also ist fehlt ist der impfstoff erst
hat die cdu widersprochen ich bin
gespannt das wird sich in den nächsten
nächsten woche auf zu erklären lassen
wer recht hat ja aber wenn das stimmt
also dass die bundeskanzlerin mit ihrem
gesundheitsminister nicht dafür gesorgt
hat dass im januar/februar genug
impfstoff da ist wo alle vom bus dann
geredet haben ich muss sagen da muss
lustig da solltet ihr einfach mal die
cdu diesmal die nächsten sechs bis acht
wochen einfach grundsätzlich okay gut
herr prantl sie haben jetzt auch keine
zeit mehr leider
ich wollte auch nur sorgen dass die
kraft die brinkhaus heute rhetorisch
gebracht hat sind für die kraft der
opposition steht dann muss sich die
regierung war man sich
gewünscht
das ist dann verlangt schon auch im
respekt ab vielen dank meine herren
fielen tag meine damen hierfür dass wir
die diskussionen vielen dank für das
interesse morgen sind wir wieder für sie
da und ist unsere letzte phoenix runde
dann in diesem jahr und dann schauen wir
mal auf das ganze krisenjahr zurück
seien sie dabei distanzschütze
[Musik]